p42 here you don't need to leave our
planet to find people who you can't
understand for some people you don't
even need to leave your own house you're
still trying to understand why your mum
has suddenly outlawed gluten and why
your dad think video games are the
devil's work well spent his whole life
playing with a model train set but with
some pointing and shouting in them you
can at least manage to communicate on a
basic level but what about if we really
came into contact with an alien species
is it realistic to think that we could
communicate and what form was that
communication tape speaking writing
emojis we can look to the early
explorers of our planet seeing how
cultures collided for the first time but
at least they were all of the same
species paintings might not be so easy
when you're trying to communicate with a
creature that has nipples for eyes and
eyes where nipple should be now
obviously our first problem is actually
finding some aliens to talk to because
it's a big old universe out there and
I'm not sure that Earth has yet made it
into the Galactic guidebook despite Ford
Prefect best effort it's often said that
the opening ceremony to the 1936
Olympics was the first message broadcast
into space and there is some truth to it
it was a high enough frequency that it
may have escaped the ionosphere and
headed out into the solar system but the
likelihood that anyone will be able to
pick it up would be incredibly small
because it doesn't have the power and
concentrated direction to get noticed
out there in the big universe it will be
lost in all the background noise so
thankfully Hitler will not be the first
face of mankind that aliens will see you
could say they will not see him coming
we have made many international attempts
both to send messages and to listen out
for them in August 1924 Mars is going to
be closer to Earth than at any point in
the past century so the u.s. decided to
have a good old little declared national
radio silence day where all radios were
silent for five minutes on the hour
every hour they used in airships to list
a radio receiver free kilometers off the
ground
so let's say we do get a message back
it's likely to be in the form of radio
waves what do we do that the first thing
is to try to work out what each part
relates to if it's mathematics and
hopefully we will know what to look out
for things like the universal constants
such as pi and a numbers that occur
throughout the universe no matter where
you are if it's language then it becomes
much more problematic since we don't
have some kind of rosetta stone for
alien the rosetta stone was a carved
rock found in the town of rosetta egypt
in 1799 it was of incredible importance
to our understanding of ancient Egyptian
hieroglyphs since it had a trilingual
inscription hieroglyphs Egyptian script
and Greek and this highlights our
problem without the comparison to base
our work off it can be impossible to
ever make a translation of a new
language we don't even need aliens to
prove this theory there are plenty of
untranslated text here on earth the live
Olympius is a manuscript from around 250
BC that was found wrapped around a
moment it's one of the few examples of
the Etruscans language from ancient
Italy and we barely managed to use any
of it there's also a language called
linear a from ancient Greeks that's
we're struggling with despite it
sounding like a Microsoft Flight plate
from the nineties and there's also
proto-elamite used for a brief 200 year
window in ancient surround
we still no idea what they were up to
and what secrets these scripts hold some
linguists have thought that perhaps
letting language evolved naturally with
all of its weird quirks and local
idiosyncrasies is not the best way to go
about things
English is taking over as the
internationals language thanks largely
to its dominance over the Internet
what attempt has been made to create a
universal language which could hopefully
make life easier when the aliens do come
to join us
Kenneth theorized created Sona in 1935
in response to some of the new
constructed languages or comm lines as
they are known such as Esperanto his
issue was that these new Khan lines were
all very European focused which was not
truly global sona was also a gluttonous
this basically means that when you
connect part together you don't change
the form or sounds or spelling which is
what most languages do and all excusing
things together make them much much more
complicated Charles K blurts a Jewish
concentration camp survivor tries to
create a written pictogram language one
that would be universal and one that
evil politicians could not manipulate
leading to the horrors that he had
witnessed
although bliss symbols never spread
around the world their logical structure
was found to be very useful in teaching
to stable children to communicate but we
don't know whether we will be speaking
or listening first when it comes to
alien communication so in order to have
our ears prepared for alien arrivals dr.
John Elliott of Leeds Metropolitan
University in England has designed a
piece of software that he hopes will be
able to tell what is and isn't the
language and if it is what patterns
it contains finding out what form the
message is actually in will be essential
if you get a JPEG from the Stars what
you think is the music is going to be
difficult to decipher the message
although you will probably make a
fortune as a pioneering new technologic
you can just see the hipsters laughing
another the Voyager probes that we sent
out into the depths of our solar system
both carry a gold disk which plays like
a record since there is music sounds and
images we use pictures of hydrogen atoms
to define the time scale since they are
the most common element and their state
change is a universal constant there is
also a diagram of how to play the record
but given that half a page of IKEA
instructions drives multiples to madness
I'm not holding out too much hope for
the aliens thanks for watching if we go
back to the Middle Ages or even all the
way back to the Roman Empire was life
ever any better than it is right now
Andrew Wakefield published a research
paper claiming that there is a strong
link between vaccinations and the onset
of autism